Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我拼不对这个词。所以你只能给一个假名字，比如你的咖啡馆名字，朱莉娅（Julia）。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你本可以在家自己做。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Assuredly, this island of land between the two great rivers, bounded on the east by the Tigris and on the west by the Euphrates, is destined to become the very crossroads of the universe. Ships from the great trading cities of the south, sailing up the Tigris, will land and drop anchor here. Here it is, that merchandise will arrive from Mosul and the lands of the north. Here too will come products transported from Syria, Egypt and beyond. The city will also
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。毫无疑问，这片位于两条大河之间、东临底格里斯河、西接幼发拉底河的土地，注定要成为宇宙的十字路口。来自南方各大贸易城市的船只，沿底格里斯河而上，将在此靠岸抛锚。就是这里，来自摩苏尔和北方土地的商品将抵达此地。来自叙利亚、埃及及更远地区的货物也将运抵这里。这座城市还将
lie on the roads taken from the east, from Iran and Khorasan. By God, I will build this city to be my capital, and it shall be my residence for the rest of my life. It shall be the residence too So that was the Caliph al-Mansur declaring his resolve to found a city at Baghdad. And Tom, that was as quoted by the 9th century geographer and historian, Yakubi. Of course it was. And what listeners don't know is that this is the second version of that introduction because your first introduction,
坐落在从东方、从伊朗和呼罗珊通往此地的道路上。向上帝发誓，我要将这座城市建成我的首都，它将是我余生的居所。它也将是……所以，这就是哈里发曼苏尔（al-Mansur）宣布他要在巴格达建城的决心。汤姆，正如 9 世纪地理学家兼历史学家雅库比（Yakubi）所引述的那样。当然是这样。听众们不知道的是，这是该开场的第二个版本，因为你的第一个版本，
Dominic, your first version achieved the ignominious fate of being the first impression that has been canned for being terrible. No, no, that's absolutely not true at all. It was a very nuanced and sensitive reading
多米尼克，你的第一个版本取得了可耻的结局，成为第一个因为太糟糕而被毙掉的开场白。不，不，那完全不是真的。那是一次非常细腻且感性的朗读，
because I did it in what I thought was a 9th century... Yeah, Theo, the producer's writing in the chat. It was too accurate. I did it in an authentic 9th century Baghdadi accent. And when we listened to it back, Tom, I couldn't help noticing that you were... You seemed beside yourself with enjoyment
因为我用的是我自认为的 9 世纪……是的，西奥（Theo），制片人在聊天里写道。它太准确了。我用的是地道的 9 世纪巴格达口音。当我们回听的时候，汤姆，我忍不住注意到你……你似乎因为享受而无法自拔，
listening to it. Yes. Well, it was so bad that it's been put in a lead-lined container and buried in the grand cellar beneath Goldhanger Towers, never to be brought out again. The truth of the matter is I've been cancelled by my own woke producers. Well, let's just draw a line under the whole business. Dominic, your second version was wonderful. We should crack on because we've got lots to do. We do. So we ended last time on a bit of a cliffhanger, didn't we?
听着它。是的。嗯，它太糟糕了，以至于被放进了一个铅衬容器里，埋在戈德汉格塔（Goldhanger Towers）下方的巨大地窖里，再也不会被拿出来了。事实是，我被我自己的“觉醒派”（woke）制片人取消了。好吧，让我们把整件事画个句号。多米尼克，你的第二个版本很棒。我们应该继续，因为我们还有很多事要做。确实。所以我们上次是在一个悬念中结束的，不是吗？
Because you brilliantly, dare I say, sketched the world of the Umayyad Caliphate. So this great empire, almost unprecedented in world history, all the way from the Straits of Gibraltar, from the Pillars of Hercules, virtually to the borders of China. A colossal Islamic realm ruled by this dynasty who were there in Damascus with kind of their silks and their slave girls and their kind of luxuriating. Sherbet. Their sherbet. I was thinking of sherbet and- Golden goblet. And babbling fountain, Tom.
因为你出色地，我敢说，勾勒出了倭马亚哈里发国（Umayyad Caliphate）的世界。这个伟大的帝国，在世界历史上几乎是前所未有的，从直布罗陀海峡，从赫拉克勒斯之柱，一直延伸到中国边境。一个庞大的伊斯兰王国，由这个王朝统治，他们在大马士革，有着丝绸、奴隶女孩和那种奢华的生活。果子露（Sherbet）。他们的果子露。我刚才在想果子露和——金酒杯。还有潺潺的喷泉，汤姆。
Yes. So there they are. Meanwhile, there are all kinds of things going on. They've suffered a few defeats. There are sectarian uprisings and kind of developing this alternative code, I suppose, of Islamic laws based on the sayings of the prophets that challenge the supremacy of the Umayyads. And you ended last time by saying, maybe all this would have been manageable were it not for the emergence of a rival dynasty. Now, as far as I remember, the stuff going on in the Far East, which I'm sure you're going to explain, but this is going to lead to a massive transformation in the Islamic world, in medieval world history, and it will of course lead to the foundation of the city of Baghdad. So, take it away please, Tom. Right.
是的。所以他们就在那里。与此同时，各种事情正在发生。他们遭受了一些失败。出现了宗派起义，并发展出了一种替代性的伊斯兰法典，我想是基于先知的言论，挑战了倭马亚王朝的统治地位。你上次结束时说，如果不是因为一个敌对王朝的出现，也许这一切都是可以控制的。现在，据我所知，远东发生的事情，我相信你会解释的，但这将导致伊斯兰世界、中世纪世界历史的巨大变革，当然也会导致巴格达城的建立。所以，请开始吧，汤姆。好的。
So, I guess the point to emphasise that we were looking at in the previous episode is that this is a world in which it's incredibly diverse. Diversity is the essence of the caliphate, all kinds of different peoples. So you talked about how the Umayyads have their capital in Damascus, but at the end of the last episode, we talked about how the Umayyad caliph Marwan has actually made himself so unpopular in Syria by destroying all his relatives and carving out his rule by means of civil war, that he's actually retreated from Syria to a city to the north called Haran, which enthusiasts for the late Roman Republic will have come across when they read
所以，我想强调的一点是，我们在上一集讨论过，这是一个极其多元的世界。多元化是哈里发国的本质，各种各样的人民。所以你谈到了倭马亚王朝如何在大马士革建立首都，但在上一集结尾，我们谈到了倭马亚哈里发马尔万（Marwan）实际上通过消灭他所有的亲属并通过内战开辟统治，使他在叙利亚变得非常不受欢迎，以至于他实际上从叙利亚撤退到了北方一个叫哈兰（Haran）的城市，晚期罗马共和国的爱好者们在阅读时会遇到这个名字，
about the Battle of Carrhae, where Crassus was killed. Carrhae and Haran are the same city. Haran is an absolutely classic example of the way in which this is still very, very far from being a Muslim Near East. Haran is actually still full of pagans. There are people who are worshipping what seem to be Babylonian gods there. They're worshipping Sin, the Lord of the Moon. They're sacrificing bulls. They're inspecting entrails. You may be wondering, how on earth can this be going on in a Muslim empire? Well, the answer is that the Hurranians, the Hurranian pagans, are passing themselves off as Sabaeans. The Sabaeans are a mysterious people mentioned in the Quran as one of the three peoples of the book, along with Jews and Christians.
关于卡莱战役（Battle of Carrhae），克拉苏（Crassus）就是在那里被杀的。卡莱和哈兰是同一个城市。哈兰是一个非常经典的例子，说明这里距离穆斯林近东还非常非常遥远。哈兰实际上仍然充满了异教徒。那里有人在崇拜看起来像是巴比伦的神灵。他们在崇拜月亮之神辛（Sin）。他们在祭祀公牛。他们在检查内脏。你可能在想，这怎么可能发生在一个穆斯林帝国里？嗯，答案是哈兰人，哈兰的异教徒，把自己伪装成萨比教徒（Sabaeans）。萨比教徒是《古兰经》中提到的三个“有经人”之一，与犹太人和基督徒并列。
Actually the Christians are very cross about this and keep saying to Marwan, you're being fooled. They're not the Sabaeans, but Marwan's fine for them to carry on. He's got bigger problems because basically rebellion is brewing in Iraq, but also in Khorasan, this vast kind of region stretching between Iran and up to the Oxus River. So for those people who don't know, this is Turkmenistan, Afghanistan, Eastern Iran, Uzbekistan maybe, sort of amorphous, huge region. Yeah. And again, it's a bit like Haran in that this is a region that's so far from the centers of power in the caliphate that again, it's a kind of very, very obvious melting pot because up there, Zoroastrianism is still very vital. There are still fire temples burning. There are still
实际上，基督徒对此非常生气，一直对马尔万说，你被骗了。他们不是萨比教徒，但马尔万觉得他们继续这样也没关系。他有更大的麻烦，因为基本上伊拉克正在酝酿叛乱，呼罗珊也是，这个广阔的地区延伸在伊朗和阿姆河之间。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，这就是土库曼斯坦、阿富汗、伊朗东部、乌兹别克斯坦，一个模糊的、巨大的地区。是的。而且，这又有点像哈兰，因为这是一个距离哈里发国权力中心非常遥远的地区，所以它又是一个非常、非常明显的熔炉，因为在那里，琐罗亚斯德教（拜火教）仍然非常活跃。仍然有火庙在燃烧。仍然有
people who yearn for the return of the Sasanian dynasty. And we talked about this in the first episode that the Persian empire that had been swallowed up by the Arab conquests, that the Persians, the Zoroastrians had been ruled by a dynasty that reached back centuries and was seen by the Zoroastrians as having a kind of holy bloodline, a sacral bloodline that had been ordained by God. And its extinction had been very, very traumatic for Zoroastrians as having a holy bloodline, a sacral bloodline that had been ordained by God, and its extinction had been very, very traumatic for Zoroastrians, for the Persians. What you have in Khorasan is this constant process by which Zoroastrian and Muslim traditions are fusing and blurring. There's a brilliant, brilliant book on this by the late, great Patricia Kroner,
人们渴望萨珊王朝（Sasanian dynasty）的回归。我们在第一集里谈到过，被阿拉伯征服所吞噬的波斯帝国，波斯人、琐罗亚斯德教徒曾被一个延续了几个世纪的王朝统治，在琐罗亚斯德教徒眼中，这个王朝拥有上帝所命定的神圣血统。它的灭亡对琐罗亚斯德教徒来说是非常、非常痛苦的。在呼罗珊，琐罗亚斯德教和穆斯林传统不断融合和模糊。已故伟大的帕特里夏·克罗内（Patricia Kroner）有一本非常、非常棒的书，
the great historian of early Islam, the nativist prophets of early Islamic Iran, which is such an interesting book. It was her last book before she died. And I commend to anyone interested in this subject. And the implications of this is that it explains why when the rebellion against the Umayyads comes, it does not originate in Iraq, even though that is kind of bubbling with resentment. And Iraq is where the Abbasids are actually waiting, this dynasty that is laying claim to the rule of the world because they are descended from Abbas, the uncle of Muhammad. It actually happens in Khorasan. And both Muslims and Zoroastrians there are seeing the world in rather similar ways. They're seeing the world as being divided into rival spheres of good and evil.
早期伊斯兰教的伟大历史学家，《早期伊斯兰伊朗的本土先知》（The Nativist Prophets of Early Islamic Iran），这是一本非常有趣的书。这是她去世前的最后一本书。我向任何对这个主题感兴趣的人推荐它。其含义在于，它解释了为什么当针对倭马亚王朝的叛乱发生时，它并非起源于伊拉克，尽管那里也充满了怨恨。伊拉克是阿拔斯王朝（Abbasids）实际等待的地方，这个王朝正宣称拥有世界统治权，因为他们是穆罕默德的叔叔阿拔斯（Abbas）的后裔。它实际上发生在呼罗珊。那里的穆斯林和琐罗亚斯德教徒都以相当相似的方式看待世界。他们将世界视为分裂为善与恶的敌对领域。
They are convinced that a great monarch is going to emerge who will be a defender of truth, a defender of God's ways, and that the man who lies, he is an oath breaker. He is a person who has trampled on the truth that he must be brought down and humbled. And these doctrines, which are very, very ancient in Zoroastrianism, are also being increasingly applied by devout Muslims towards the Umayyads. I think that this explains the slightly mysterious quality of the outbreak of the Abbasid revolution. In 745, a figure appears in Khorasan by the name of Behatharid. Behatharid dresses in green, which is the color of a Zoroastrian deity called Mir. He brandishes a book written in Persian. He claims to be an agent of light. He's clearly a very, very Zoroastrian figure, but he is also
他们确信一位伟大的君主将会出现，他将是真理的捍卫者，上帝道路的捍卫者，而那个撒谎的人，他是一个背誓者。他是一个践踏真理的人，必须被推翻和羞辱。这些在琐罗亚斯德教中非常、非常古老的教义，也越来越多地被虔诚的穆斯林应用于倭马亚王朝。我认为这解释了阿拔斯革命爆发时那种略带神秘的特质。745 年，一个名叫贝哈法里德（Behafarid）的人物出现在呼罗珊。贝哈法里德身穿绿色，这是琐罗亚斯德教神灵米尔（Mir）的颜色。他挥舞着一本用波斯语写的书。他声称自己是光明的代理人。他显然是一个非常、非常琐罗亚斯德教的人物，但他也是
claiming to be the messenger of God, which is the title of Muhammad. So you can see there the fusion of Zoroastrian and Islamic traditions happening. And Iranian peasants flock to him. It seems that the whole of Khorasan is going to be consumed by a revolution led by this mysterious figure clad in green. But he gets captured in 749. He gets hanged outside a mosque. But here's the thing, Dominic. The people, the Muslims who have captured Behafarid and and put him to death are themselves the followers of a figure who is very, very like Bahá'u'lláh. And this is a very, very enigmatic figure called Abu to be the agent of God. His identity is unknown. It's unclear whether he's an Arab or a Persian, whether he's an aristocrat or what is much likely a reformer slave. And when people ask him, well, who are you? Where do you come from? He replies in enigmatic terms, the knowledge of my deeds is better for you than the knowledge
声称自己是上帝的使者，这是穆罕默德的头衔。所以你可以看到琐罗亚斯德教和伊斯兰传统的融合正在发生。伊朗农民蜂拥而至。似乎整个呼罗珊都将被这位身穿绿衣的神秘人物领导的革命所吞噬。但他于 749 年被捕。他在清真寺外被绞死。但重点是，多米尼克。那些俘虏了贝哈法里德并将他处死的穆斯林，他们自己也是一个非常、非常像巴哈欧拉（Bahá'u'lláh）的人物——这是一个非常、非常神秘的人物，名叫阿布·穆斯林（Abu Muslim）——的追随者，他声称自己是上帝的代理人。他的身份不明。不清楚他是阿拉伯人还是波斯人，是贵族还是更可能是改革派奴隶。当人们问他，你到底是谁？你从哪里来？他以神秘的措辞回答，了解我的事迹比了解我的
of my pedigree. That's the kind of thing David Cameron used to say. I know it's not. When people say to him, how can a former, you know, old Etonian run the country? He'd say, it doesn't matter where I'm from. It's where I'm going. I was thinking, I was thinking more about Batman. Oh, Batman. Yeah. He's a kind of a mysterious superhero who's emerged and, you know, cloaked and masked. We have very different images of Abu Muslim. I think, I think that the listeners want to put David Cameron from their minds. Abu Muslim is nothing like David Cameron. He is much more like Batman. Okay, continue.
血统对你更有益。那正是大卫·卡梅伦（David Cameron）过去常说的那种话。我知道不是。当人们对他说，一个前伊顿公学学生怎么能治理国家？他会说，我来自哪里并不重要。重要的是我要去哪里。我当时在想，我当时在想蝙蝠侠。哦，蝙蝠侠。是的。他是一个神秘的超级英雄，出现了，你知道，披着斗篷，戴着面具。我们对阿布·穆斯林的形象有很大的不同。我想，我想听众们想把大卫·卡梅伦从脑海中赶走。阿布·穆斯林一点也不像大卫·卡梅伦。他更像蝙蝠侠。好吧，继续。
He's a mysterious, enigmatic figure. And he is an agent of the Abbasids. This is the key. That's the thing. He's not working for himself, right? Has he been suborned? Has he been put up to this by this emerging rival dynasty?
他是一个神秘、难以捉摸的人物。他是阿拔斯王朝的代理人。这是关键。这就是重点。他不是为自己工作，对吧？他被收买了吗？他被这个新兴的敌对王朝指使了吗？
He may well be. I mean, the likeliest theory is actually he was a slave, probably a Persian in Iraq, and he gets sent to Khorasan precisely because he is able to appeal to the Iranians there and because he will be a kind of neutral figure. And that's why he kind of preserves his mysterious identity. But it enables him basically to cast himself again as an agent of God. And he is able to preach to the Iranians out there that the Abbasids are a family appointed to world rule by God, exactly as the Sasanians have been. So they're kind of tapping into that. Right. So they're picking up on the Persian tradition, but Tom, just remind us from last time, who are the Abbasids again? The Abbasids are the descendants of Abbas, who is the uncle of Muhammad.
他很可能。我的意思是，最可能的理论是，他实际上是一个奴隶，很可能是伊拉克的波斯人，他被派往呼罗珊正是因为他能够吸引那里的伊朗人，而且因为他将是一个中立的人物。这就是为什么他保留了他神秘的身份。但这使他基本上能够再次将自己塑造为上帝的代理人。他能够向那里的伊朗人传教，说阿拔斯家族是上帝任命的世界统治者，就像萨珊王朝一样。所以他们是在利用这一点。对。所以他们是在拾起波斯传统，但汤姆，提醒我们一下上次的内容，阿拔斯家族到底是谁？阿拔斯家族是阿拔斯的后裔，他是穆罕默德的叔叔。
Right. And they have been doing what in the interim since those days? Are they like minor dignitaries? Are they governors? They've been kind of hanging out, you know, being Arab warlords. Right. They haven't been persecuted or anything. But because you have this, it's articulated by the Shias who think that it's the bloodline of Ali. It's still very much present in Persian popular imagination. The idea of a family with a sacred bloodline who can be appointed by God to bring about an age of equality and justice is very, very potent, particularly in the eastern reaches of what had been the Persian Empire. And this is what the Abbasids are tapping into.
对。从那时起，他们一直在做什么？他们是小官员吗？他们是总督吗？他们一直都在，你知道，做阿拉伯军阀。对。他们没有受到迫害什么的。但因为你有这个，它是由什叶派（Shias）阐明的，他们认为这是阿里（Ali）的血统。它在波斯大众的想象中仍然非常存在。一个拥有神圣血统的家族，可以被上帝任命来带来一个平等和正义的时代，这种想法非常、非常强大，特别是在曾经是波斯帝国的东部地区。这就是阿拔斯家族所利用的。
And that's why they send their agent basically to the old Zoroastrian heartlands. And it's why it's so successful there, I think. I think that what Abu Muslim, even though he suppressed the Zoroastrian prophet, and he himself, there's no question, is a very devout Muslim. Nevertheless, he is making play with Zoroastrian traditions and telling the mass of the Iranian peasantry, look, the Abbasids are the embodiment of what you want. These are the people who have been appointed by God. They share the blood of the prophet in their veins. They have been appointed by God to bring about this new age of justice. And he does this in this incredibly dramatic moment, doesn't he? The 9th of June, 747. He unfurls this flag.
这就是为什么他们基本上把他们的代理人派往古老的琐罗亚斯德教中心地带。我认为这就是它在那里如此成功的原因。我认为，尽管阿布·穆斯林镇压了琐罗亚斯德教的先知，而且他本人毫无疑问是一位非常虔诚的穆斯林。然而，他利用了琐罗亚斯德教的传统，并告诉广大伊朗农民，看，阿拔斯家族就是你们想要的化身。这些人是上帝任命的。他们血管里流着先知的血。他们被上帝任命来带来这个新的正义时代。他在这个极其戏剧性的时刻做到了这一点，不是吗？747 年 6 月 9 日。他展开了这面旗帜。
And both the colour of the flag and the place that he does it are significant. Is that right? So it's a black flag. Like a pirate. The black flags of the Abbasids. But he does it in a village outside the great city of Merv, where the last Sasanian king had perished while he was fleeing from the Arabs. So that would kindle Persian memories, would it?
旗帜的颜色和地点都很重要。是这样吗？所以这是一面黑旗。像海盗一样。阿拔斯家族的黑旗。但他是在大城市梅尔夫（Merv）外的一个村庄里做的，最后一个萨珊国王在逃离阿拉伯人时就在那里丧生。所以这会点燃波斯的记忆，是吗？
Right. So again, it doesn't imply that Abu Muslim has any sympathy whatsoever with the Sasanians. He's not interested in them, as I say, he's a Muslim, but it does tap into kind of buried loyalties. And he's trying to transfer those loyalties to the Abbasids. This is a tradition that is commemorated for many centuries. Long, long later in the Seljuk era, you have a tradition that, I'll quote, whenever he was alone with Zoroastrians, he would say, according to one of the books of the Sasanians which I have found, the Arab empire is finished. Now, this isn't true. There's no way that he's trying to bring about a return of the Sasanian Empire, but it does suggest that it's recognized by people in these lands that it's going with the grain of Zoroastrian traditions. And it's kind of offering Iranians a chance to redeem their dignity that had been lost
对。所以这并不意味着阿布·穆斯林对萨珊王朝有任何同情。他对此不感兴趣，正如我所说，他是一个穆斯林，但这确实触及了某种被埋藏的忠诚。他正试图将这些忠诚转移到阿拔斯家族身上。这是一个被纪念了许多世纪的传统。很久很久以后，在塞尔柱（Seljuk）时代，有一个传统，我引用一下，每当他与琐罗亚斯德教徒单独在一起时，他就会说，根据我发现的一本萨珊王朝的书，阿拉伯帝国完了。不，这不是真的。他绝不是试图让萨珊帝国回归，但这确实表明，这些土地上的人们认识到，这符合琐罗亚斯德教传统的脉络。这有点像给伊朗人一个机会，去挽回他们失去的尊严，
for so long. And it's a very, very potent strategy, and it proves highly successful. So the fires of rebellion, Dominic, we love a fire of rebellion, don't we? It spreads very, very fast. Absolute tinderbox. So by 748, actually on Valentine's Day, so the 14th of February, Abu Muslim has captured Merv. The following year in March, he has marched into Iran. He defeats an Umayyad force at Isfahan in Western Iran. And that effectively secures him the whole of the Iranian plateau. By August, he has gone down into Iraq, into Mesopotamia. He's gone across the Euphrates. And by September, he has captured
太久了。这是一个非常、非常有效的策略，事实证明非常成功。所以叛乱的火焰，多米尼克，我们喜欢叛乱的火焰，不是吗？它蔓延得非常、非常快。绝对是火药桶。所以到 748 年，实际上是在情人节，也就是 2 月 14 日，阿布·穆斯林占领了梅尔夫。第二年 3 月，他进军伊朗。他在伊朗西部的伊斯法罕击败了一支倭马亚军队。这有效地确保了他对整个伊朗高原的控制。到 8 月，他进入了伊拉克，进入了美索不达米亚。他穿过了幼发拉底河。到 9 月，他占领了
Kufa, which is this great city founded by the Arab armies, great kind of sectarian breeding ground for Karajites and Shiites and Sunni lawyers and all kinds of people. And it's there on the 28th of November that Abu al-Abbas, who is the great grandson of Muhammad's uncle, is proclaimed as caliph. And he is one of many brothers. He's not by any means the eldest brother, so he has older brothers. He's in his late twenties. He had arrived in Kufa prior to the arrival of Abu Islam's forces, but had been kept in a safe house. But this doesn't imply in any way that he's a kind of, you know, he's a wuss or coward or whatever. He's not at all. He's a very forceful, very driven, and as events will prove, very brutal figure. And this will be exemplified by his throne name.
库法（Kufa），这是阿拉伯军队建立的一座伟大城市，是哈瓦利吉派（Karajites）、什叶派、逊尼派律师和各种各样的人的宗派温床。就在 11 月 28 日，穆罕默德叔叔的曾孙阿布·阿拔斯（Abu al-Abbas）被宣布为哈里发。他是众多兄弟中的一个。他绝不是长兄，所以他有哥哥。他二十多岁。他在阿布·穆斯林的军队到达之前就已经到达了库法，但一直被安置在一个安全屋里。但这并不意味着他是一个，你知道，懦夫或胆小鬼什么的。他根本不是。他是一个非常有力量、非常有动力，而且事实证明，非常残暴的人物。这将由他的王号来体现。
So when a caliph extends, he takes a throne name. And his, Dominic, is Asafa, the Shedder of Blood. Good title. Very good title. Meanwhile, this has all been going on in the East, but the Umayyad caliph Marwan, who you described last time, curly-haired fellow, grizzled, and experienced and accomplished soldier, by the way, not a wimp or a waste of space. What's he up to while all this is going on? Well, he's got a problem because the basis
所以当哈里发即位时，他会取一个王号。多米尼克，他的王号是萨法（Asafa），即“嗜血者”。好头衔。非常好的头衔。与此同时，这一切都在东方发生，但你上次描述的倭马亚哈里发马尔万，那个卷发、灰白头发、经验丰富且成就卓著的士兵，顺便说一句，不是懦夫或废物。这一切发生时他在做什么？嗯，他有一个问题，因为
for a man of power are the Syrians and the Syrian soldiers are the elite, but they're scattered thousands of miles across the caliphate. And so it's going to take him time to gather them, but he doesn't have time. So essentially what he does is he gathers what forces he can. It still massively outnumbers the Abbasid army. He heads out from Haran, heads down towards the Euphrates. On the 25th of January, 750, he sees, Dominic, on the horizon, the black banners of the Abbasids. Marwan leads his troops across a river called the Great Zab. Good name. Which is a brilliant name and a tributary of the Tigris.
权力的基础是叙利亚人和叙利亚士兵，他们是精英，但他们分散在哈里发国数千英里之外。所以他需要时间来召集他们，但他没有时间。所以他基本上所做的是召集他能召集的部队。它仍然在数量上大大超过了阿拔斯军队。他从哈兰出发，向幼发拉底河进发。750 年 1 月 25 日，多米尼克，他在地平线上看到了阿拔斯家族的黑旗。马尔万带领他的部队穿过一条叫大扎布河（Great Zab）的河流。好名字。这是一个绝妙的名字，是底格里斯河的一条支流。
And he burns the bridges to ensure that his troops won't run away, that they'll have to stand and fight. As I say, hugely outnumber the Abbasids. They have a great force of cavalry, but the Abbasids have brought pikemen. And pikemen are always very effective against cavalry. So when the Umayyads charge the Abbasid lines, they form a shield wall, pikes bristle out like porcupines. And an Abbasid who fought in the battle, he remembered how the Syrians attacked us like mountains of iron. But when we knelt down
他烧毁了桥梁，以确保他的部队不会逃跑，他们必须站住战斗。正如我所说，他们在数量上大大超过了阿拔斯军队。他们有一支强大的骑兵部队，但阿拔斯军队带来了长矛兵。长矛兵对付骑兵总是非常有效的。所以当倭马亚军队冲向阿拔斯防线时，他们组成了盾墙，长矛像豪猪一样竖起。一位参加过这场战斗的阿拔斯士兵回忆说，叙利亚人像铁山一样攻击我们。但当我们跪下
and prepared our spears, they turned from us like a cloud. And Marwan's army tries to flee, but they can't. They can't get across the bridge. Because he'd burn the bridges. He'd burn the bridges. So kind of classic error. So it's a kind of comprehensive defeat for the Umayyads. Marwan himself seems to have received a head injury, but he's not going to give up. He manages to get across the river. He flees to Haran. He then goes down to Damascus. No one in Damascus really wants to help him. No one in Jerusalem wants to help him. He flees to Egypt, being pursued the whole way by Abbasid agents. So very like Dominic,
并准备好长矛时，他们像云一样从我们身边散去。马尔万的军队试图逃跑，但他们做不到。他们无法过桥。因为他烧毁了桥梁。他烧毁了桥梁。所以这是一种经典的错误。所以这对倭马亚王朝来说是一场全面的失败。马尔万本人似乎头部受了伤，但他并不打算放弃。他设法过了河。他逃往哈兰。然后他去了大马士革。大马士革没有人真正想帮他。耶路撒冷也没有人想帮他。他逃往埃及，一路上一直被阿拔斯代理人追捕。所以非常像多米尼克，
Alexander pursuing Darius, if you remember. Same kind of dynamic. And then Bessus after that into Afghanistan. But Marwan actually gets cornered by his pursuers at a village in Egypt. His head is chopped off, his tongue is removed and fed to a cat, which is a splendid detail. And Marwan's head is then brought to Safa, the bloodshedder, the caliph. And Marwan's death is announced on the steps of the great mosque in Kufa by al-Safa's brother, Dawud. Praise be to God with gratitude, gratitude, and yet more gratitude. Praise be to him who has caused our enemies to perish and brought us to our inheritance from Muhammad our prophet. God's blessing and peace be upon him." Safa merits his name by absolutely, obsessively hunting down every last Umayyad that he can. The shedder of blood. He sheds
亚历山大追捕大流士（Darius），如果你还记得的话。同样的动态。然后是贝苏斯（Bessus）逃往阿富汗。但马尔万实际上在埃及的一个村庄被追捕者逼到了绝境。他的头被砍了下来，舌头被割下来喂了猫，这是一个精彩的细节。马尔万的头随后被带到了萨法，那个嗜血者，哈里发面前。马尔万的死讯由萨法的兄弟达乌德（Dawud）在库法大清真寺的台阶上宣布。赞美上帝，怀着感激、感激，还有更多的感激。赞美他，他使我们的敌人灭亡，并带我们继承了我们先知穆罕默德的遗产。愿上帝保佑他，赐他平安。”萨法通过疯狂地、执着地追捕每一个他能找到的倭马亚人来配得上他的名字。嗜血者。他流了
a lot of blood. I think we actually talked about this in our episode on the worst parties. The last living Umayyads are brought into Safa's presence and he orders them to be completely butchered, you know, all wiped out. And then the bodies are kind of laid out. A carpet is laid over the bodies and tables are laid kind of on the carpet. And it is said those who were present at the scene ate while the death rattle still sounded in the throats of the expiring victims. Crikey. That's a dinner party. So the living are extirpated, but so too, Dominic, are the dead.
很多血。我想我们实际上在关于最糟糕派对的那一集里谈到过这个。最后活着的倭马亚人被带到萨法面前，他下令将他们全部屠杀，你知道，全部消灭。然后尸体被铺开。地毯铺在尸体上，桌子摆在地毯上。据说，当在场的人用餐时，垂死受害者的喉咙里还发出死亡的咯咯声。天哪。那真是一场晚宴。所以活人被铲除了，但多米尼克，死人也是。
So Sapphire orders the tombs of the Umayyad caliphs to be dug up. Corpses were scourged with whips. Some of them were crucified. Archers used the skulls for target practice and then smashed into little pieces. And then all the remains of the Umayyad caliphs were gathered up and burnt to ashes. So very, very comprehensive extirpation of the ruling dynasty. And the only one who escapes, you may remember Abd al-Rahman, who makes all the way to Spain, where in the long run, his dynasty, the Umayyads will survive and set up a new caliphate.
所以萨法下令挖出倭马亚哈里发的坟墓。尸体被鞭打。有些人被钉在十字架上。弓箭手用头骨进行射击练习，然后把它们砸成碎片。然后所有倭马亚哈里发的遗骸都被收集起来烧成灰烬。所以对统治王朝进行了非常、非常全面的铲除。唯一逃脱的人，你可能记得阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼（Abd al-Rahman），他一路逃到了西班牙，从长远来看，他的王朝，倭马亚王朝将在那里幸存下来并建立一个新的哈里发国。
And we did that in the World Cup, didn't we, for Spain? We did. But Spain is so far away that this doesn't really impinge on the glory of the Abbasid triumph. And Safa basically spends the four years that he's granted of ruling as caliph, killing as many of his enemies as he possibly can. And then in 753, he dies of smallpox. And he is succeeded by his elder brother, Abu Jafar, who takes the throne named Dominic of the victorious one, Al-Mansur. And people remember the brilliant rendering of exactly how he spoke at
我们在世界杯上做过那个，不是吗，为了西班牙？我们做过。但西班牙太远了，这并没有真正影响到阿拔斯胜利的荣耀。萨法基本上把他作为哈里发统治的四年时间都花在了尽可能多地杀掉他的敌人上。然后在 753 年，他死于天花。他的哥哥阿布·贾法尔（Abu Jafar）继位，他取了王号，多米尼克，胜利者，曼苏尔（Al-Mansur）。人们记得他在本集开头
the start of this episode. So that is Al-Mansur. And I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we will get to the founding of Baghdad, which is the great achievement of Almanzor. Brilliant. So come back after the break and Almanzor will be founding Baghdad. See you then. Woo. Chiara, it means smart in Italian.
的精彩演讲。所以这就是曼苏尔。我想我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将谈到巴格达的建立，这是曼苏尔的伟大成就。太棒了。所以休息后回来，曼苏尔将建立巴格达。到时候见。呜。基亚拉（Chiara），在意大利语中是聪明的意思。
Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Giulia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute, what kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你只能给一个假名字，你的咖啡馆名字，朱莉娅（Giulia）。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等，朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你本可以在家自己做。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to TheRestIsEntertainment.com. That's TheRestIs the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history so we ended last time with the arrival on the scene of al mansoor he is a very impressive man isn't he he's in his late 20s people say he's a very impressive man, isn't he? He's in his late 20s. People say he's a very tall, lean, regal-looking figure. But he's not a great party animal of what makes them so unpopular with pious Muslims and has contributed to the Abbasid revolution. Al-Mansur is a very, very pious Muslim,
我们共同主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。那是 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以我们上次以曼苏尔的登场结束，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，不是吗？他二十多岁，人们说他是一个非常高大、瘦削、有王者风范的人物。但他不是那种派对动物，这使他们在虔诚的穆斯林中如此不受欢迎，并促成了阿拔斯革命。曼苏尔是一位非常、非常虔诚的穆斯林，
so he doesn't drink. He very much disapproves of music. And people may be wondering, are there going to be any eunuchs in this story? Well, there are. So one day he hears the sound of a mandolin being played in his palace, absolutely shocked, and tracks it down, discovers that it's a eunuch playing the mandolin. So he orders the instrument to be broken over the eunuch's head and the miscreant to be hauled out of the palace and sold in the slave market. So that is how he treated musicians, Dominic. Right. Okay. That's a warning there for, yeah. Yes. For anybody making music. Yeah. He's also like Sapphire, the shedder of blood. He's also pretty brutal. So Justin
所以他不喝酒。他非常不赞成音乐。人们可能在想，这个故事里会有太监吗？嗯，有的。所以有一天，他在宫殿里听到曼陀林的声音，感到非常震惊，并追踪到了它，发现是一个太监在弹奏曼陀林。于是他下令把乐器在太监头上砸碎，并把这个作恶者拖出宫殿，卖到奴隶市场。这就是他对待音乐家的方式，多米尼克。对。好吧。这对任何做音乐的人来说都是一个警告。是的。他就像萨法，那个嗜血者。他也相当残暴。所以贾斯汀·马罗齐（Justin Marozzi），
Marozzi, whose book Baghdad, City of Peace, City of Blood is a wonderful history of the entire city. He says of Al-Mansur, the caliph's executions were so numerous that there were times when the historian wonders how he found the time to attend to other affairs of state. And you've read that, haven't you? There's a brilliant story about what happens after Al-Mansur has died. And he's given a key to his daughter-in-law and said that, you know, this is the key to the storeroom. You must on no account open it until I'm dead. And then he actually dies on pilgrimage to Mecca. And the news comes back to Baghdad, which is built by this point. And the daughter-in-law and her husband, the new caliph think,
他的书《巴格达：和平之城，鲜血之城》（Baghdad, City of Peace, City of Blood）是整座城市的一部精彩历史。他这样评价曼苏尔：哈里发的处决如此之多，以至于有时历史学家会怀疑他怎么有时间处理其他国家事务。你读过那个，不是吗？有一个关于曼苏尔死后发生的事情的精彩故事。他给了他的儿媳一把钥匙，说，这是储藏室的钥匙。在我死之前，你绝对不能打开它。然后他实际上在去麦加朝圣的路上去世了。消息传回了当时已经建成的巴格达。儿媳和她的丈夫，新哈里发想，
oh, brilliant, let's go and find out what daddy has left in the storeroom. And do you want to take up the story? Yeah. So they go in and they think it's all going to be treasured, don't they? And they go in and they actually find
哦，太棒了，让我们去看看爸爸在储藏室里留下了什么。你想讲这个故事吗？是的。所以他们进去了，他们以为那里面全是财宝，不是吗？他们进去了，实际上发现
it's piles and piles and racks and racks of the dead bodies of the descendants of the Caliph Ali. That's right, isn't it, Tom? Yes. So the Shia. Yeah. Then lovely details.
那是堆积如山的哈里发阿里（Ali）后裔的尸体。那是对的，不是吗，汤姆？是的。所以是什叶派。是的。然后是可爱的细节。
They've all been labeled and tagged to say who, because they must be rotting by this point. So it's like, oh, this is great uncle Ibrahim. This is so-and-so. This is so-and-so. Yeah. I love the fact that he's been so diligent, Tom, about collating and identifying all the bodies. Well, it's the collating and identifying all the bodies.
他们都被贴上了标签，说明是谁，因为到这个时候他们肯定已经腐烂了。所以就像，哦，这是伟大的叔叔易卜拉欣（Ibrahim）。这是某某。这是某某。是的。我喜欢这样一个事实，汤姆，他一直如此勤奋地整理和识别所有的尸体。嗯，这是整理和识别所有的尸体。
Well, it's the fusion of brutality and bureaucracy. Yes. But sadly, it probably didn't happen. No, it almost certainly didn't happen. But it's the kind of story that his reign generates, because he very rapidly becomes the archetype of a great ruler, which of course is exactly what the Abbasid revolution was supposed to stop. The Abbasid revolution was supposed to be all about introducing a reign of justice and equity and making the teachings of the Quran manifest on the earth. But actually Al-Mansur is having none of that. So one of the reasons why he is persecuting the family of Ali is that he wants to enshrine the rule of his own family, the Abbasids. And it becomes clear very quickly
嗯，这是残暴与官僚主义的融合。是的。但遗憾的是，它可能没有发生。不，它几乎肯定没有发生。但这是他的统治所产生的那种故事，因为他很快就成为了伟大统治者的原型，而这当然正是阿拔斯革命本应阻止的事情。阿拔斯革命本应是关于引入一个正义和公平的统治，并使《古兰经》的教义在地球上显现。但实际上曼苏尔对此一无所知。所以他迫害阿里家族的原因之一是他想巩固他自己家族，即阿拔斯家族的统治。这很快就变得清晰起来
to disillusion supporters of the Abbasid revolution that basically, here's the new boss, same as the old boss. They had appealed to the Shia. Yeah, they had. Wasn't that part of the thing? And now they're basically- Suckers. Yeah, right. Oh dear. But I mean, you know what I'm saying? He's brutal. He's faintly hypocritical. He doesn't like music,
对于阿拔斯革命的幻灭支持者来说，基本上，新老板和旧老板一样。他们曾呼吁什叶派。是的，他们曾呼吁。那不是其中的一部分吗？现在他们基本上——傻瓜。是的，没错。哦，亲爱的。但我的意思是，你知道我在说什么吗？他很残暴。他有点虚伪。他不喜欢音乐，
but he is a hugely impressive ruler. He's probably the most impressive ruler since Abdul Malik, the greatest of the Umayyad caliphs. And he marshals the economy very effectively. So the extravagance that had been the hallmark of the Umayyads, he stops that. He's nicknamed Abu Dawanik, which one translation is daddy's small change, because he counts every last dirham, every last dinar. You need that in a rule of thumb. You do. There's a kind of famous maxim of his that is quite kind of mafiosi. He who has no money has no men and he who has no men watches as his foes wax great. So he's aware of what the
但他是一位极其令人印象深刻的统治者。他可能是自阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik）——倭马亚哈里发中最伟大的一位——以来最令人印象深刻的统治者。他非常有效地管理了经济。所以倭马亚王朝标志性的奢侈，他停止了。他被昵称为“阿布·达瓦尼克”（Abu Dawanik），一个翻译是“小钱之父”，因为他计算每一个迪拉姆，每一个第纳尔。你在拇指规则中需要那个。你需要。他有一句著名的格言，相当像黑手党：没有钱的人就没有人，没有人的话，就只能看着敌人变得强大。所以他意识到他的
basis of his power is, that it's money and it's men. But he does also have an absolutely authentically global sense of his mission, which is an Islamic one. As I say, he's a very pious Muslim. And he feels that to set his own dynasties and the caliphate's power on a firm footing, he needs a capital. And so that then begs the question of where should the capital be? So there were various options. It could have Damascus. The Umayyad capital, basically. The Umayyad capital, beautiful mosque there, which still stands, famous Muslim city, but very associated with the Umayyads. And there's a further problem with that, that the Abbasid
权力基础是什么，那就是金钱和人。但他确实有一种绝对真实的全球使命感，这是一种伊斯兰使命感。正如我所说，他是一位非常虔诚的穆斯林。他觉得要让自己的王朝和哈里发国的权力建立在稳固的基础上，他需要一个首都。所以这就引出了一个问题，首都应该在哪里？所以有各种选择。它可以是大马士革。基本上是倭马亚首都。倭马亚首都，那里有美丽的清真寺，至今仍屹立不倒，著名的穆斯林城市，但与倭马亚王朝联系非常紧密。还有一个进一步的问题，阿拔斯
power base basically is Iranian. They came to power by means of the revolution in Khorasan. So really, Damascus is too far to the west. The need to keep Iran and Khorasan on side explains why Abu Muslim, for instance, is very rapidly dispatched. Yeah, I was wondering what happened to him. So he comes on pilgrimage from Khorasan and he gets invited to Al-Mansur's party and that's the end of him. And even though there's a revolt in Khorasan, Al-Mansur is able to suppress it. So he's good at taking calculated risks, I think. But that just emphasises for him the fact that he needs a capital that's going to look eastwards rather than westwards as the American capital at Damascus had done. So he could found it in Kufa, but the problem with Kufa has always been
权力基础基本上是伊朗的。他们是通过呼罗珊的革命上台的。所以真的，大马士革太靠西了。保持伊朗和呼罗珊的支持的需要解释了为什么阿布·穆斯林，例如，被非常迅速地打发走了。是的，我一直在想他发生了什么事。所以他从呼罗珊来朝圣，他被邀请参加曼苏尔的派对，那就是他的结局。即使呼罗珊发生了叛乱，曼苏尔也能够镇压它。所以他擅长承担经过计算的风险，我想。但这只是向他强调了一个事实，即他需要一个向东看而不是像大马士革的美国首都那样向西看的首都。所以他可以在库法建立它，但库法的问题一直在于
that it's absolutely rife with sectarian tensions. There are so many Shiites there, so many Karajites there. It's a real problem. And basically, Al-Mansur comes to the conclusion that Kufa breeds heresy. So he establishes a camp on the outskirts of Kufa and his Persian guards end up reclaiming Al-Mansur a god. And when he objects to this, they try to kill him. And so he has them all killed, but he decides this is no good either. Haran, the capital of Marwan, again, rife with pagans. And so he decides that he's going to build a new capital from scratch. And he decides it's got to be in Mesopotamia. Mesopotamia is the richest possession in the entire caliphate. It's very conveniently connected
它绝对充满了宗派紧张局势。那里有太多的什叶派，太多的哈瓦利吉派。这是一个真正的问题。基本上，曼苏尔得出的结论是库法滋生异端。所以他在库法郊外建立了一个营地，他的波斯卫兵最终称曼苏尔为神。当他反对这一点时，他们试图杀了他。于是他把他们全部杀掉，但他决定这也不行。哈兰，马尔万的首都，同样充满了异教徒。所以他决定他要从零开始建立一个新的首都。他决定它必须在美索不达米亚。美索不达米亚是整个哈里发国最富有的领地。它连接得非常方便
to the east. He goes sailing up and down the River Tigris looking for the perfect spot. He settles on a tiny village called Baghdad. Baghdad is not an Arab word, it's a Persian word meaning a gift from God. It's one of a number of very Christian villages, lots of monasteries. Almansoor buys up the whole lot and decides that this is where he is going to found his capital. Aside from the fact that it has very, very convenient links to Khorasan, it's also on the trade links between the Persian Gulf, so Basra, and the Mediterranean. Yeah. This is why in the passage that you so beautifully read at the start, he says, this city is going to be the crossroads of the universe. And basically that's
向东。他沿着底格里斯河航行，寻找完美的地方。他定居在一个叫巴格达的小村庄。巴格达不是一个阿拉伯词，它是一个波斯词，意思是上帝的礼物。它是许多非常基督教的村庄之一，有很多修道院。曼苏尔买下了整个地方，并决定这就是他要建立首都的地方。除了它与呼罗珊有非常、非常方便的联系之外，它还在波斯湾（即巴士拉）和地中海之间的贸易路线上。是的。这就是为什么在你开头读的那段话中，他说，这座城市将成为宇宙的十字路口。基本上这就是
what Baghdad becomes. Al-Mansur's aim is that Baghdad will be the centre of the world. And that's basically what it does indeed become. Because it becomes the most populous city, the richest city on earth, doesn't it for a time? It does. But before we get to that, Tom, tell us how it's built. So Almanzor arrives in the spring of 762, and his engineers outline the new city's walls in cinders. And then the day that is chosen for the foundation, it's chosen by two royal astrologers, and the date is variously given as the 30th of July or 2nd of August.
巴格达所成为的样子。曼苏尔的目标是让巴格达成为世界的中心。基本上它确实成为了。因为它成为了人口最多的城市，地球上最富有的城市，不是吗，有一段时间？是的。但在我们谈到那个之前，汤姆，告诉我们它是怎么建造的。所以曼苏尔在 762 年春天到达，他的工程师用煤渣勾勒出了新城市的城墙。然后选择建立的那一天，是由两位皇家占星家选择的，日期有 7 月 30 日或 8 月 2 日等不同说法。
It's sometime around then. And it's Mansur, of course, who lays the first brick. And it takes four years to complete the initial stage of the capital. And then 768, he starts building an extension on the far side of the Tigris. And these are linked by pontoon bridges. Lots of land around the city are given to soldiers from Khorasan. So basically, you basically, it's kind of free land. This solves the problem of how do you keep your soldiers on board and give them
大约就在那时。当然是曼苏尔铺设了第一块砖。完成首都的初始阶段花了四年时间。然后在 768 年，他开始在底格里斯河的另一侧建造扩建部分。这些由浮桥连接。城市周围的大量土地被分给了来自呼罗珊的士兵。所以基本上，你基本上，这是一种免费的土地。这解决了如何让你的士兵保持一致并给他们的问题。
land. And very rapidly, you're starting to get slums develop as well, because it's obvious that this is going to be the place to be. And Baghdad is given the official name of Madinat As-Salam, the city of peace. Now, what does it look like? The problem we have is that the foundation established by Al-Mansur, nothing has survived at all. So we're dependent on written sources. And a lot of these, there's a reason why Baghdad becomes the fabled city of the Arabian Nights. Some clearly very tall stories are told about it. But having said that, there is a kind of consensus in the sources that you can kind of arrive at. And the most striking thing about it is that the city that is initially built by Mansur is a circle, an absolutely perfect circle. So Al-Jahiz, who is a famous essayist,
土地。而且很快，贫民窟也开始发展起来，因为很明显这里将成为人们向往的地方。巴格达被赋予了官方名称“和平之城”（Madinat As-Salam）。那么，它看起来是什么样子的呢？我们面临的问题是，曼苏尔建立的基础设施几乎没有留下任何痕迹。因此，我们只能依赖书面资料。其中很多资料之所以让巴格达成为《一千零一夜》中传说般的城市，是有原因的。关于它的一些故事显然非常夸张。但话虽如此，这些资料中确实存在一种可以达成共识的观点。最引人注目的是，曼苏尔最初建造的城市是一个圆圈，一个绝对完美的圆圈。所以，著名的散文家贾希兹（Al-Jahiz），
who actually ends up being crushed to death when a great pile of books fall on him. That's a warning to us all, Tom. Warning to us all. He says of Baghdad that it's such a perfect circle that it is as if it was poured into a mould and cast. So you have a moat, you have two massive walls. These walls are estimated to have been anything from one to four miles in circumference. The outer wall is 60 feet high. The inner wall is 90 feet high. So these are massive, massive walls. There are only four gates. These gates are located midway between the four cardinal directions, so north, east, south, and west. And the gateways are spectacular. So you have cupolas. These are over the gatehouse. These are supported by columns
他实际上最终被一大堆倒下的书压死了。汤姆，这对我们所有人都是一个警告。对我们所有人都是一个警告。他谈到巴格达时说，它是一个如此完美的圆圈，就好像它是倒入模具中铸造出来的一样。所以你有一条护城河，还有两道巨大的城墙。据估计，这些城墙的周长在1到4英里之间。外墙高60英尺。内墙高90英尺。所以这些是非常、非常巨大的城墙。只有四个城门。这些城门位于四个方位之间，即北、东、南、西。城门非常壮观。你有圆顶。这些圆顶位于门楼上方。它们由柚木柱支撑，
of teak. The coloring of these gatehouses, green on the outside, gold ceilings. So to go into Baghdad, you know that you are entering the most spectacular, the most beautiful city on the face of the planet. Each of these gates, straight roads leading to the very center of the city lined with vaulted arcades. And beyond these arcades, there are various bazaars, which are, of course, incredibly rich because Baghdad attracts merchandise from across the world. And these are there for the first years of Baghdad's existence. But then a Byzantine emissary comes and points out to Mansur that bazaars breed mobs and that mobs are capable of turning on emperors. And this, of course, is something that the Byzantines are well aware of. And so Mansur, you know, he says, whatever, no one would attack me.
这些门楼的颜色是外绿内金。所以当你进入巴格达时，你知道你正在进入地球上最壮观、最美丽的城市。每一座城门都有通往城市中心的笔直道路，道路两旁是拱形长廊。在这些长廊之外，有各种各样的集市，当然，这些集市极其富裕，因为巴格达吸引了来自世界各地的商品。在巴格达存在的最初几年里，这些集市一直存在。但后来一位拜占庭使节向曼苏尔指出，集市会滋生暴民，而暴民有能力反抗皇帝。当然，拜占庭人对此非常清楚。所以曼苏尔说，无所谓，没人会攻击我。
And then a few months later, he orders all the bazaars out and they are moved to a place called Kark, which becomes the kind of the great commercial industrial hub of the city, and that's outside the circular walls. And actually, the west part of Baghdad is still nicknamed Kark to this day, isn't it? To this day, from that, yeah. And then you have this kind of third innermost wall, and beyond this innermost wall, you have a great central enclosure, and inside it, you have a mosque and a palace. And this is a pious recreation of how Muhammad had lived at Medina, where he had a mosque and there were living quarters for his various wives. So even though the buildings here are massive, there is a sense in which Al-Mansur is paying tribute to the prophet because both these buildings are on a massive scale.
几个月后，他下令将所有集市迁出，它们被搬到了一个叫卡尔克（Kark）的地方，那里成为了城市主要的商业和工业中心，位于圆形城墙之外。事实上，巴格达的西部至今仍被称为卡尔克，不是吗？确实如此。然后你有了第三道最内层的城墙，在这道最内层城墙之外，有一个巨大的中央围场，里面有一座清真寺和一座宫殿。这是对穆罕默德在麦地那生活方式的虔诚重现，他在那里有一座清真寺，还有供他各位妻子居住的住所。因此，尽管这里的建筑规模宏大，但在某种意义上，曼苏尔是在向先知致敬，因为这两座建筑的规模都非常宏大。
So 360,000 feet is Justin Marozzi's estimate in his book, The Mosque, so vast. And the palace, it's called the Palace of the Golden Gate. It has an enormous 120 foot high green dome above the main audience chamber. This is an emulation of what the Emead's done. So Emead Palace has had green domes, but again, absolutely nothing on this scale. And again, you get a sense of the way in which the stupendous quality of this very rapidly starts to shade into myth because there are stories that on the top of the dome, there is a statue of a horseman with a lance and that this horseman will turn and point the lance in whatever direction the next enemy to confront the caliph is expected to come from.
贾斯汀·马罗齐（Justin Marozzi）在他的书《清真寺》中估计面积为36万平方英尺，非常广阔。那座宫殿被称为“金门宫”。在主觐见大厅上方有一个巨大的120英尺高的绿色圆顶。这是对倭马亚王朝做法的效仿。倭马亚宫殿也有绿色圆顶，但规模完全无法相比。你再次感觉到这种惊人的品质很快就开始带上神话色彩，因为有故事说，在圆顶顶部有一尊骑马者的雕像，手里拿着长矛，这位骑马者会转动身体，将长矛指向哈里发可能面临的下一个敌人到来的方向。
And within this great central enclosure, no one except for Mansur himself is allowed to ride a horse. So even his relatives, if they're ill, they're not allowed to get on a horse. And Tom, the people who moved to Baghdad, so the caliph moves in, his bodyguards, his nobles, whatever, his advisors, but all the people who are piling in, are they, what, economic migrants from other parts of the empire? Are they largely from Iran or from Mesopotamia? Do we have any sense of that? You have his courtiers and you have the soldiers from Khorasan who've been given lands, rather like Octavian gives lands to his legions after he's defeated Antony, same kind of idea. But inevitably, you have people who are flocking to where the caliph is. I mean, this is where the action is. So yeah, you have people from
在这个巨大的中央围场内，除了曼苏尔本人，没有人被允许骑马。所以即使是他的亲戚，如果生病了，也不允许骑马。汤姆，那些搬到巴格达的人，哈里发搬进去了，他的保镖、贵族、顾问等等，但所有涌入的人，他们是来自帝国其他地区的经济移民吗？他们主要是来自伊朗还是美索不达米亚？我们对此有什么了解吗？你有他的朝臣，还有来自呼罗珊的士兵，他们被授予了土地，就像屋大维在击败安东尼后将土地分给他的军团一样，是同样的想法。但不可避免地，人们会蜂拥到哈里发所在的地方。我的意思是，这就是行动中心。所以是的，你有来自
across the entire world coming to Baghdad. And that means that the city is endlessly growing. So Mansur himself, I mean, amazingly, he decides he's a bit fed up with his palace in the middle of the round city. So he builds another one called the Palace of Eternity down by the banks of the Tigris, I guess, because it's cooler there. You're getting the, you know, the airs from the river. And he also builds another extension, another palace on the far side of the banks. So on the Western banks of the Tigris. And it's just enormous. And even Byzantine ambassadors coming from Constantinople are kind of stupefied by it, stupefied by the wealth, by the beauty, and by the absolute perfection of the round qualities of these great central walls in the heart of Baghdad.
世界各地的人来到巴格达。这意味着这座城市在不断扩张。曼苏尔本人，令人惊讶的是，他对自己圆城中间的宫殿感到有点厌倦。所以他在底格里斯河畔又建了另一座宫殿，叫“永恒宫”，我想是因为那里更凉快。你可以感受到来自河流的微风。他还建了另一个扩建部分，在河的另一边，也就是底格里斯河的西岸，又建了一座宫殿。它简直太巨大了。甚至连从君士坦丁堡来的拜占庭大使都被它惊呆了，被它的财富、美丽以及巴格达中心这些巨大城墙的绝对完美的圆形品质所震撼。
And this becomes a great source of pride to Baghdadis later in centuries on. So one of them, who writes a history of Baghdad in the 11th century, he says of Baghdad, there is no other round city that is known of in all the regions of the world. So he sees it as being completely unique, but Dominic, here's the thing. It's not at all unique. Oh, Tom, what a twist. Because actually various cities in the Sasanian empire had been circular. Right. So even Iran had been kind of oval, but the Sasanians had actually been very keen on circular cities. And that's a reflection of the fact that although we think Baghdad is an Arab
这后来成为了几个世纪后巴格达人的巨大骄傲。其中一位在11世纪撰写巴格达历史的人说，在世界所有地区，没有其他已知的圆形城市。所以他认为它是独一无二的，但多米尼克，问题在于，它根本不是独一无二的。哦，汤姆，真是个反转。因为实际上萨珊帝国中的各种城市都是圆形的。没错。所以即使是伊朗也曾是椭圆形的，但萨珊人实际上非常热衷于圆形城市。这反映了一个事实，尽管我们认为巴格达是一座阿拉伯
city, the designers and the architects seem almost certainly to have been Persian. So the design of the mosque, the mosque does not have a dome in the center of the round city. It's actually modeled on Persian examples of architecture that goes ultimately all the way back to Persepolis. There's a little touch of the court of the King of Kings in the mosque in the center of Baghdad. And if the association of palace and mosque in the middle of Baghdad echoes the example of Muhammad, it also echoes the example of the Sasanian kings who had fused fire temples with palaces in their own cities. Even one of the astrologers who fixes the date for the founding of Baghdad, he's a Zoroastrian convert. The weird thing about Baghdad is that almost everything about it suggests a culture that is ultimately Persian and therefore actually much older than Mansur himself.
城市，但其设计者和建筑师几乎可以肯定是波斯人。所以清真寺的设计，圆城中心的清真寺并没有圆顶。它实际上是仿照波斯建筑的例子，最终可以追溯到波斯波利斯。巴格达中心的清真寺里有一点“万王之王”宫廷的影子。如果巴格达中间宫殿和清真寺的结合呼应了穆罕默德的例子，它也呼应了萨珊国王的例子，他们在自己的城市中将火神庙与宫殿融合在一起。甚至连确定巴格达奠基日期的占星家之一，也是一位琐罗亚斯德教的皈依者。巴格达奇怪的地方在于，关于它的一切几乎都暗示了一种最终属于波斯，因此实际上比曼苏尔本人更古老的文化。
So even though Baghdad is a new city, its roots are actually surprisingly deep and it reflects a seismic development in the history of Islam and therefore of the world, which is that the orientation of Islam from this point on will definitely be Persian rather than Roman. So Tom, just to focus in on that. So when Islam emerged, it emerged in a world heavily influenced by the Romans on a frontier, I guess. So at first, the Romans themselves thought it was a kind of, you know, those first fragmentary sources say, well, is it a kind of Jewish heresy? Is it an offshoot to Christianity? Who knows what it is? So the Arabs have taken over a lot of the old of Baghdad, there is a massive fracture point, which is that now what we think of as the Middle East is looking away from the West, from the Mediterranean, and looking more towards Persia, basically. I think so. The Umayyads were notorious for impersonating Caesars. This was one of the
所以尽管巴格达是一座新城市，但它的根基实际上出奇地深，它反映了伊斯兰教乃至世界历史上的一次地震式发展，那就是从这一点开始，伊斯兰教的导向将明确地转向波斯，而不是罗马。所以汤姆，重点关注这一点。当伊斯兰教出现时，它出现在一个深受罗马人影响的世界里，我想是在边境上。所以起初，罗马人自己认为这是一种，你知道，那些最早的零碎资料说，嗯，这是一种犹太异端吗？它是基督教的分支吗？谁知道它是什么？所以阿拉伯人接管了许多旧的巴格达，这里有一个巨大的断裂点，那就是现在我们所认为的中东正在背离西方，背离地中海，基本上更多地转向波斯。我想是这样。倭马亚王朝以模仿凯撒而闻名。这是针对他们的
many accusations that were levelled against them. If you think of the Dome of the Rock, it's like a Byzantine church. Yeah, it's like the great church in Constantinople, right? Yeah. The great mosque that the Umayyads built in Damascus, that had originally been a cathedral, but before a cathedral, it had been a temple to Zeus. So it's literally built within the shell of a Roman pagan temple. And there is a sense that the endless attempts to try and capture Constantinople are because the Umayyads feel that they can only properly be world emperors if they're ruling it from the capital of Caesar. But with the Abbasids and with the founding of
众多指控之一。如果你想到圆顶清真寺，它就像一座拜占庭教堂。是的，就像君士坦丁堡的大教堂，对吧？是的。倭马亚人在大马士革建造的大清真寺，最初是一座大教堂，但在成为大教堂之前，它曾是一座宙斯神庙。所以它实际上是建在罗马异教神庙的外壳内。有一种感觉，即不断试图占领君士坦丁堡是因为倭马亚人觉得只有在凯撒的首都统治，他们才能真正成为世界皇帝。但随着阿拔斯王朝和
Baghdad, that orientation, that sense that it's the Roman example that is there to be emulated, or rather to be drawn on, perhaps I should say, for cultural and ideological sustenance. That fades and increasingly it's the Persian example. But it's not just the Persian because I'm sure people who have heard the episodes that we did on Babylon, when I'm talking about the great walls, the great religious structures and palaces in the heart of the city, will be reminded of Babylon. Now, this is not conscious, but Babylon is only about 40 miles from where Baghdad is. And there are other cities as well. So there's Seleucia, which had been the great Hellenistic capital, Ctesiphon, which had been the Sasanian capital. These are pretty much on the doorsteps of Baghdad. And in fact, Ctesiphon provides raw materials for the building of Baghdad. Even if Mansur himself is not
巴格达的建立，那种导向，那种认为罗马的例子是值得效仿的，或者更确切地说，应该说是为了文化和意识形态的滋养而借鉴的，那种感觉正在消退，波斯的例子正日益占据主导地位。但这不仅仅是波斯，因为我相信听过我们关于巴比伦那一集的人，当我谈到城市中心的巨大城墙、伟大的宗教建筑和宫殿时，会想起巴比伦。现在，这不是有意的，但巴比伦距离巴格达只有约40英里。还有其他城市。比如塞琉西亚，它曾是伟大的希腊化首都，泰西封，曾是萨珊王朝的首都。这些几乎就在巴格达的家门口。事实上，泰西封为巴格达的建设提供了原材料。即使曼苏尔本人并没有
consciously drawing on these exemplars, scholars in Baghdad do recognize the fact that the placement of Baghdad in what they can recognize as the great birthplace of civilization is significant. There's the court astrologer in the earliest days of Baghdad. He writes that the people of every age and era acquire fresh experiences and have knowledge renewed for them in accordance with the decree of the stars. So there's that idea that Baghdad is the latest iteration of cycles of great cities that have risen and fallen, but that Baghdad is the culmination of it because it can absorb the learning and the experience of all the cities that have gone before it. So it's the climax of world history?
有意识地借鉴这些典范，巴格达的学者们确实认识到，巴格达位于他们所能认知的伟大文明发源地这一事实意义重大。在巴格达早期的宫廷占星家写道，每个时代和纪元的人们根据星辰的旨意获得新的经验并更新知识。所以有一种观点认为，巴格达是兴衰更替的伟大城市循环的最新迭代，但巴格达是它的巅峰，因为它能够吸收之前所有城市的学习和经验。所以它是世界历史的高潮？
Yes, because just as Jews and Christians and Zoroastrians have been absorbed into the Caliphate, just as the Roman and Iranian provinces have been absorbed into it, so is the past being absorbed into an Islamic future. Baghdad is the summation of all the civilizations that have gone before it. And this is basically why representatives of the superseded faiths are perfectly welcome in Baghdad. So I said one of the astrologers that says the date on which it should be founded is Zoroastrian, the other one is a converted Jew. The court physicians are Christian.
是的，正如犹太人、基督徒和琐罗亚斯德教徒被吸收到哈里发国中一样，正如罗马和伊朗各省被吸收到其中一样，过去也被吸收到伊斯兰的未来中。巴格达是之前所有文明的总和。这基本上就是为什么被取代信仰的代表在巴格达完全受欢迎的原因。所以我说其中一位占星家说奠基日期是琐罗亚斯德教的，另一位是皈依的犹太人。宫廷医生是基督徒。
Christians are famous as doctors. And within only a few decades of the founding of Baghdad, the Eastern Patriarch will be enshrined in Baghdad and made very welcome. But there's also a sense in which, symbolically, trophies are being brought to Baghdad that symbolize older civilizations. So the gates on the four great gates that lead into the circular city, the story goes that originally they were made by demons out of iron for Solomon. One is said specifically to have been of pharaonic workmanship. By pharaonic, it doesn't mean it comes from Egypt, but from a pagan temple, probably in Syria. These gates are pre-Islamic, but the point is that they have now been absorbed
基督徒以医生身份闻名。在巴格达建立后的几十年内，东方牧首将被供奉在巴格达并受到热烈欢迎。但从象征意义上讲，也有一些战利品被带到巴格达，象征着更古老的文明。所以通往圆形城市的四座大门，故事说它们最初是恶魔用铁为所罗门制造的。其中一座据说是法老工艺。所谓法老，并不意味着它来自埃及，而是来自一座异教神庙，可能在叙利亚。这些城门是前伊斯兰时期的，但重点是它们现在已经被吸收
into the urban fabric of an Islamic city. You can see economically, in terms of trade policy, in terms of its ability to command the high roads that lead out to the limits of the frontier in terms of psychogeography, in terms of culture, in terms of architecture. Baghdad is a brilliant, brilliant foundation. Everyone immediately recognises that this is a city that, even though it's barely been in existence, Mansur dies, as we said earlier, on pilgrimage to Mecca in 775. By the time of his death, everyone absolutely accepts that Baghdad is the place to be, that it is a beautiful, haunted place. And that's kind of amazing considering it's the Milton Keynes of... I'm glad you said that at the end and not at the beginning, because we wouldn't have any listeners,
进了伊斯兰城市的城市肌理中。你可以从经济上、贸易政策上、指挥通往边境极限的高速公路的能力上、心理地理学上、文化上、建筑上看到，巴格达是一个极其出色的奠基。每个人都立即认识到，这是一座城市，尽管它几乎才刚刚存在，曼苏尔正如我们之前所说，于775年在去麦加朝圣的路上去世。在他去世时，每个人都绝对接受巴格达是人们向往的地方，它是一个美丽而令人着迷的地方。考虑到它是……的米尔顿凯恩斯，这真是太神奇了。我很高兴你在最后而不是在开头说了这句话，因为那样我们就不会有任何听众了，
apart from people in Milton Keynes, of course. Actually, in Milton Keynes, they were very keen on psychogeography as well. The chief designer was a druid. I've written about Milton Keynes, Tom. I'm actually quite a big fan of Milton Keynes. Anyway, this is an unexpected development. Let's just leave this episode by saying that Baghdad has been founded. The boast of Mansur, that it will become the crossroads of the universe, has been fulfilled.
当然，除了米尔顿凯恩斯的人。事实上，在米尔顿凯恩斯，他们也非常热衷于心理地理学。首席设计师是一位德鲁伊。汤姆，我写过关于米尔顿凯恩斯的文章。我实际上是米尔顿凯恩斯的忠实粉丝。总之，这是一个意想不到的发展。让我们以巴格达已经建立来结束这一集吧。曼苏尔的豪言壮语，即它将成为宇宙的十字路口，已经实现了。
It's a global crossroads, but it's also a crossroads of the universe has been fulfilled. It's a global crossroads, but it's also a crossroads where past and future, where various traditions, various understandings of the divine all meet, and that this sets it up for what will become an absolutely dazzling golden age. It's the reason why, I guess, Assassin's Creed have decided that Baghdad deserves to rank alongside Alexandria as one of the totemic urban centers of human civilization. So the good news is, Tom, we finally got within 100 years of the period that the introduction to the last episode was set in.
它是一个全球十字路口，但它也是一个宇宙的十字路口，这一目标已经实现。它是一个全球十字路口，但它也是一个过去与未来、各种传统、各种对神性的理解汇聚的地方，这为它后来成为一个绝对令人眼花缭乱的黄金时代奠定了基础。我想这就是为什么《刺客信条》决定巴格达值得与亚历山大港并列，成为人类文明的图腾城市中心之一。所以好消息是，汤姆，我们终于进入了上一集介绍中所设定的时期100年之内了。
At last, we are approaching what we'll be talking about next week, which is even more exciting than what we've done so far. So we will be talking about the golden age of Baghdad, the Islamic golden age, this extraordinary zenith of arts and philosophy and mathematics and science and all kinds of drama. And of course, the world of the Arabian Nights and Harun al-Rashid and all of this stuff.
终于，我们正在接近下周要讨论的内容，这比我们目前所做的还要令人兴奋。所以我们将讨论巴格达的黄金时代，伊斯兰黄金时代，这个艺术、哲学、数学、科学和各种戏剧的非凡巅峰。当然，还有《一千零一夜》的世界、哈伦·拉希德以及所有这些东西。
So we've got all that to look forward to next week. Of course, if you remember the Rest is History Club, you know the drill. You get all kinds of lovely sherbets and sort of dancing girls dancing sweetmeats and all that kind of stuff don't you and you also get the chance to listen to episodes early which is the real attraction but the rest of you we will well we will join you next week hopefully and tom thank you very much and on that note goodbye goodbye Goodbye. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde.
所以下周我们有很多值得期待的内容。当然，如果你记得“历史就是一切”俱乐部，你就知道规矩了。你会得到各种可爱的果子露、跳舞的女孩、甜点等等，不是吗？你还有机会提前收听剧集，这才是真正的吸引力。但对于你们其他人，我们希望下周能见到你们，汤姆，非常感谢你，就此告别。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。